[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing severus snape
albus dumbledore and perhaps one of the
most iconic moments in the entire harry
potter franchise
i am of course talking about the scene
from the deathly hallows
where dumbledore says to snape after all
this time
to which snape responds always i've
noticed that this scene has been
misinterpreted by
some people and i did see some comments
asking for a video on it so i just
wanted to oblige
as we know snape was originally a death
eater and was on the side of lord
voldemort
he changed allegiance after his love
interest lily potter
was murdered by the dark lord snape who
was unsure of what to do next after her
murder
was then persuaded by dumbledore to
honor lily's memory
by protecting harry this meant switching
sides
the following excerpt from the deathly
hallows depicts this
if you loved lily evans if you truly
loved her
then your way forward is clear snape
seemed to peer through a haze of pain
and dumbledore's words appear to take a
long time to reach him
what what do you mean you know how and
why she died
make sure it was not in vain help me
protect lily's son
so what some people have been left
asking themselves after this scene
is why would dumb would dumbledore be
surprised that snape's motivations
remain the same
after all this time dumbledore seems
genuinely surprised
that snape is still acting out of his
love for lily which to me seems peculiar
the following passage depicts the
conversation between dumbledore and
snape
that prompts their famous exchange of
these impactful lines
you have used me meaning i have spied
for you and lied for you
put myself in mortal danger for you
everything was supposed to be to keep
lily potter's son safe
now you tell me you've been raising him
like a pig for slaughter
but this is touching severus said
dumbledore seriously
have you grown to care for the boy after
all for him
shattered snape expecto patronum
from the tip of his wand burst the
silver doe she landed on the office
floor
bounded once across the office and sawed
out of the window
dumbledore watched her fly away and as
her silvery glow faded
he turned back to snape and his eyes
were full of tears
after all this time always
what's unusual about dumbledore's
genuine surprise is that dumbledore
seemingly
suddenly cast a certain level of doubt
over snape's commitment to honoring
lilly
after all it was the basis for snape's
allegiance to the order
doesn't dumbledore's absolute trust of
snape imply that he was completely
confident that snape's motivations were
unchanged
the reason that dumbledore is shocked
and says after all this time
is not because he ever questioned
snape's loyalty or allegiance to the
order
he never doubted snape's intentions and
knew that he would always vow to honor
lily
snape's commitment was for the rest of
his life the reason that dumbledore
says after all this time is because he's
amazed by snape's patronus
a doe we know that lily potter's
patronus was also a doe
and it's well known that if you love
someone your patronus can change to
match the patronus of the person that
you love the patronus charm is known to
express the nature of the caster
and is linked to significant events or
people in one's life
you can't choose your patronus or change
it willfully
and the fact that snape's patronus was
still a doe matching lily
after all that time was representative
of the fact that he truly loved lily
and that his feelings for her hadn't
weakened over the years it was the
depths of snape's love
that hit dumbledore so hard and brought
him to tears
and that's the reason that he
experiences genuine shock
and surprise when snape produces it so
dumbledore's surprise at snape was never
anything to do with his allegiance
and was everything to do with the depth
of his love for lily potter
it had been almost 17 years since lilly
died
but she still meant everything to him
and that's it for this video
if you guys have any other video ideas
or questions about the books or films
be sure to leave them in the comment
section below until next time you're a
wizard harry